[Music]
the 69th annual Emmys are approaching so
we're having a little fun and throwing
it back 15 years to 2002 when Hollywood
was just a little different
fifteen years ago the Osbourne's debuted
their reality show on MTV and Will and
Grace was still on the air the only
thing is is I may have accidentally lied
a little the show's leading lady Debra
Messing's a total babe walked the red
carpet in this long-sleeved brown dress
while co-star Megan Mullally opted for a
pantsuit friends was in its eighth
season on NBC and Jennifer Aniston took
home one of the show's very first Emmys
winning the category of lead actress in
a comedy series it's just a really nice
icing on the cake
it's been a really good cake and can you
believe she was still married to Brad
Pitt the two looked happy as ever on the
red carpet Jen rocked this now-famous
sparkly pink dress and Oh Brad those
bangs as for the other famous couples
who were still happily together Courtney
Cox brought David Arquette as her date
while heather locklear enjoyed a night
out with Richie Sambora and Jennifer
Garner was all about her hubby no not
Ben Affleck her felicity co-star Scott
Foley Nolan I started going out it began
really well
meanwhile Ellen DeGeneres was dating
actress alexandra hedison and then there
was Oprah
see you later have a good time radio
showed off her slimmed down frame in
this glamorous pale yellow ball gown
this is some big award
Oprah this is a big award in 2002 Oprah
added the Bob Hope Humanitarian Award to
her shelf of then 30 Emmy trophies that
blew me away I really I'm right like I'm
having an out-of-body experience
[Music]
you